un bar comme il y en a peu sur la
planète dédié uniquement aux échecs
ce soir il ya foule des gens de tous les
âges venus pour un tournoi au beau
milieu de la semaine
[Musique]
tout ça c'est grâce à magnus sur ce
joueur amateur magnus c'est magnus
carlsen 28 ans champion du monde depuis
un prodige qui inspire beaucoup
norvégien au point où celle en tournoi
qui peuvent s'étirer sur plusieurs
heures sont diffusées en direct à la
télévision nationale devant public et
commentateurs une passion qui ne se
limite pas à la télévision en public et
dans les transports
ils sont nombreux à jouer aux échecs sur
leur téléphone une fièvre des échecs qui
a débuté ici dans cette école où la
norvège forme ses futurs olympiens
adolescents magnus carlsen s'est
entraîné entre ses murs c'est un héros
national une inspiration lance cet
étudiant qui consacre tous ses temps
libres aux échecs il a une soif de
conquête qui en amène certains à viser
très haut
avec de tels objectifs
il faut saisir chaque occasion de
s'améliorer pour johannes hague
ce soir c'est l'occasion d'observer mais
ce soir pas question de jouer dans ce
tournoi d'amateurs à 19 ans son niveau
de jeu est bien supérieur à celui de
l'ensemble des participants cette
canadienne n'a aucune illusion sur ses
compétences aux échecs mais il y voit
une occasion d'affaires qui dépasse les
applications pour téléphones
intelligents quête me fit crois que
l'effet magnus et la technologie peuvent
tenir les passionnés du jeu à l'échelle
de la planète géant qui semble bien
éveillé en norvège johannes s'est
finalement laissé tenter par une partie
avec un inconnu
c'était pour le plaisir mais ils lavent
et remporter il n'a que 19 ans il
excelle à ce noble jeu mais déjà il a
conclu qu'il n'en ferait pas une
carrière
une logique implacable
il ne sera jamais aussi fort que magnus
casse etc a régalé ça il faut l'accepter